[Applaus]
bela b ist bei uns sind nicht gleich zu
beginn gerne fragen würde wähler hast du
lieber ernsthaft mit dem thema
altersvorsorge beschäftigt halt nie also
da wo ich herkomme
also diese ganze punkrock sache und so
da haben wir so ein hedonistisches
weltbild gehabt was hat uns nicht
interessiert ehrlich gesagt ja wir
hatten ein kreuz vergab sogenannte
volksküchen das sind arme leute hin
gegangen da sind aber auch die die punks
die sich gerne haben generiert haben
also weil die natürlich auch arme punks
oder gar auch die die halt so dass die
auch gestört haben obwohl das gar nicht
wussten was cool war mit der 10 18
irgendwie haben es da keine gedanken
drüber gemacht also ich hab ich habe ja
eine lehre durchgezogen als
lagerarbeiter man ja gearbeitet und so
war auch zwei wochen bei der polizei 116
du hast zwei wochen bei der polizei ja
das passt ja und dann habe ich ja über
die jahre auch immer wieder als musiker
war ich irgendwie in
arbeitsverhältnissen von denen ich aber
nicht so richtig ahnung hat auf jeden
fall habe ich einen anspruch auf 120
euro wenn nicht sondern rente geht hat
nicht aber ehrlich gesagt nicht
interessiert geständig gerne dann im
moment geht das kann nicht mehr sagen
ich glaube das kann ich dann auch wieder
alle zwei wochen bei der polizei
[Musik]
wahrscheinlich habe ich habe da einen
aufnahmetest gemacht mit 15 und mit 16
festgestellt das ist nicht mein ding
habs dann aber zwei wochen gemacht weil
ich zwei wochen im einsatz wirklich im
einsatz war ich noch einmal da habe ich
herrn kohl geschützt
das war gar nicht so einfach mal vor
hast du einmal vor wir waren wir waren
jubelt die jubel touristen am zaun als
ich es gerade star war zu besuch
staatsbesuch und der cholerische stars
da sind die straßen gegangen und die die
erste reihe am zaun war besetzt mit
polizeischülern oder beamten jungen
beamten in brasilien natürlich nach so
natürlich und ihr wart dazu angehalten
zujubeln wenn es kalt ist und genau
genommen haben kaffee getrunken und dann
kommt er kommt dann sind wir los habe
ich von weitem gesehen und sind jeden
falsche richtung kranken und dann mit
dem chaos hatten wir dann nichts mehr zu
tun und so die bahn kam die idee auf das
gesagt aus der lehre gemacht als
dekorateurin soll den lehrberuf gibt es
nicht mehr
aber da hast du aus ordnung gemacht da
ich eine ausbildung gemacht ja ich
wollte eigentlich grafiker werden aber
meine mutter dachte dass er ist ein
beruf ohne zukunft heute gibt es den
schaufensterdekorateur nicht mehr aber
zum glück ist ja dann mit 19 was anderes
aus mir geworden
da haben wir arzt gegründet und genau
dann ging es los
reden wir gleich ausführlicher darüber
springen jetzt einmal nach vorne
du hast einen roman geschrieben roman
genau ich habe mir gedacht als ich das
gehört habe okay ärzte immer gute texte
also die haben sich mit mit wort
beschäftigt wie können schreiben
definitiv und das ist toll geschrieben
aber es ist ein roman wie würdest du ihn
beschreiben
es ist ja es ist ein heimatroman zwar
dass man später in der deutschen provinz
150 kilometer von berlin und da
passieren seltsame dinge ganz profane
dinge also leute
treffen komische entscheidung wie jeden
tag auf der welt leute komische
entscheidung treffen zum beispiel nackt
einen supermarkt zu überfallen oder
solche dinge ganz so rahn parallel
passieren wirklich fantastische seine
geschichte mit dem überfall der vier
nach hinten auf den supermarkt gibt es
dafür eine reale entsprechung
er ist oder werden reale entsprechung
das ist das sicher eine geschichte die
ein freund mir mal erzählt hat auf dem
dorf in nordrhein westfalen haben drei
nackte allerdings sah ich habe das ein
bisschen ausgeschmückt abend hatte die
drei männer die die nase gut verfremdet
werden tagen bringen die haben dann
tatsächlich wollten mehr alkohol
zigaretten und da ein bisschen was zu
knabbern und ordnern in den supermarkt
ihres dorf ist es gab ja nur ein
supermarkt kein problem wird maskieren
uns strumpfmaske ja weil wir haben ja
jeden tag dieselben klamotten
dann gehen wir dahin nack 3 das fand ich
schon mal total super aber was mich
wirklich zum umdenken gebracht hat die
sind da rein in den supermarkt ja und
drei grobschlächtige typen und haben
dann aber nur zigaretten alkohol und
manches mitgenommen und raub begangen
und warum machen die das meeting stunts
beratern seit haben die einen kodex
haben die irgendwie doch geht das gegen
ihre ehre da noch geld denn sie sich
schon mal dabei sind und so und so wurde
dann so habe ich dann da so eine
kurzgeschichte darum kreiert und aus der
kurzgeschichte wurde dann längere
geschichte es gab andere geschichten ich
dann hinzugefügt habe und dann wurde am
rund 416 seiten draußen ja aber man hat
ja
da drinnen gibt es aber anders dann
gedruckt ist ja lustig so quer sozusagen
zum buch gedruckt gibt es unter anderem
sollen manifest genau das wagenpark der
glücklichen was hat es damit auf sich
genau das sind diese das sind diese vier
männer die diesen supermarkt überfallen
und die haben das sind aussteiger
zuallererst mal sind die anti digital
das gefiel mir sehr gut die gucken nur
vhs videos trinken nur und wollen mit
mit der ihrer umwelt so wenig wie
möglich zu tun hatte gehen halt nur
einkaufen in einem supermarkt den sie
dann aber überfallen weil sie kein geld
mehr haben und und die hatten hat die
haben ein manifest in dem sie 21 regeln
glaube ich sind das ja festgelegt haben
die für ihr glück verantwortlich sind
hat viel mit alkohol zu tun aber auch
andere gesagt ich habe 33 habe ich mir
aufgeschrieben weil ich die sehr
unterhaltsamen er eine der regel du
darfst viel geld ausgeben fürs trinken
haushalte aber wenn zum saufen geht nun
ist die eine die zweite bedacht alleine
trinken aber niemals alleine saufen und
eine andere die mir persönlich am besten
gefällt am leben bleiben bis man stirbt
[Applaus]
ja ja das haben die das handy als
aushang in ihrer wohnung damit umgehen
da immer dran vorbei ist lässt sich da
die zugemauerte küche das ist eine
geschichte auch in dem buch und dann
gehen sie wenn man daran vorbei und
denken okay das ist mein leben am leben
bleiben bis man stirbt wenn einer wie du
so ein buch macht sein erster roman
vorlegt wedelt da der verleger direkt
mit großen scheinen also man hat gar
schon gut zu hören
also das ding war so dass ich dass ich
tatsächlich ein angebot bekam von drei
jahren und einem kleinen verlag aus
österreich im residenz verlag und
renommierter verlage klein ist ja auch
nicht so klein ist ja auch nicht immer
an thomas bernhard veröffentlicht die
und die fragten ob ich in einer
quereinsteiger reihe art aufsatz
schreiben und da hatte ich dachte ich
okay überzeugt mache ich habe ich noch
nie gemacht mache ich mal an meine
managerin
damals war der damalige die sagte behle
vielleicht ist das das einzige was du in
deinem leben schreibt sie ist ein
bisschen größer aus macht ein bisschen
größer und lasse auch andere verlage da
vielleicht ein bisschen möglichkeit sich
da anzubieten und den mit einem verlag
mit dem ich sehr viel zu tun hatte die
waren sehr interessiert dann wurde es
der eine verlagen und dann wollten dem
buch haben super ich mache eine
kurzgeschichtensammlung und sagen sie ja
super kurzgeschichten technologien
liegen sind liegen wie blei in den
regalen aber manchmal ist jetzt haben
wir schon mal zugesagt als ihn sagt ich
machen roman haben sie dann schon
wir haben hier einen anständigen
vorschuss gezahlt aber die ich jetzt
neulich bei einem anderen kollegen wenn
ich jetzt sagen darf na ja wo ich sage
den namen bitte takis würger haben
kolportieren sicher ganz andere summen
also insofern das war es nicht so ja ich
verdienen das auch lieber das geld das
kommt vielleicht sogar zu dem thema
wieder ich verlieren ist lieber durch
verkaufte auflage als jetzt alles im
vorschuss und dann sind alle sauer am
ende aber es sieht gut aus und hat dazu
sagen zu dem vorstoß der sich dem
zurückgehalten habe bis letzten sommer
also nicht ausgegeben habe weil ich mir
offen gehalten habe dass es den
zurückzuzahlen weil ich mir nicht sicher
war ob dass sich das auf die welt
loslassen will
ja man hat ja auch oft zu verlieren weil
er seinen ruf zu verlieren ist einer wie
du nervös wenn er dann seinen ersten
roman veröffentlicht davor habe ich
keine angst im ruf zu verlieren er auch
keine angst vor kritik oder sowas es ist
eher so dass ich dann also ich habe er
gedacht so so so hin und hergespielt
bräuchte das vielleicht ist das ein
halbfertiges ding oder so irgendetwas
mag ich so auf drei viertel des weges
kannst du gar nicht was hast du so viel
schon geschrieben das muss jetzt raus
und eigentlich so ab ende august letzten
jahres war ich überzeugt es ist gut
genug und du sagst ist sie so gut dass
ich heute selber immer wieder drei vier
seiten darin lesen und denken noch heiß
ist gut das ist also überzeugt
[Applaus]
das buch liegt rom nicht immer schnell
zur hand drei seiten und bisher einmal
aber okay da sind ein paar wiederholung
nicht so super aber ansonsten gefällt
mir das so spannend also ordentlich zu
stehen also ich höre mir ja auch meine
eigenen platten an wenn die fertig sind
ja nicht lange aber zumindest bis zur
tour um mal wieder weil ich dann auch
stolz bin froh bin dass ich das gemacht
habe was das ist immer dann also in dem
moment wurde das mal lasst mal zum
nächsten drüber gehen das stimmt
irgendwas nicht also man sollte auch
schon stolz sein weil wir gerade wieder
über vorschüsse und geld verdienen und
so weiter sprechen wie war das am anfang
mit den ärzten mit mit 19 wann habt ihr
das erste geld verdient als ärzte das
weiß ich noch
wir haben am anfang waren wir dann hand
im mund gelegt wir lebten von urlaub und
ich ja mit einer wg zusammen in einer
wohnung auch da ist das findet in meinem
buch auch ein versprechen dass
tatsächlich die küche war so hat so
gestunken dass wir mit dem gedanken
gespielt haben sie zu machen hat er aber
nicht gemacht
[Applaus]
für mich nicht putzen sondern zu mauer
genau genau kenne also jan hat ein
bisschen geld von seinem vater bekommen
und wenn wir einmal die miete bezahlen
mussten wir haben damals sind wir
brauchten nicht wann er dünn war cool
ist irgendwann irgendwie total
abgemagert typen und haben dann hat er
hat den metro ausweisen konnten wird der
nation so so kartoffelpüree rom mast
horten und manchmal fischstäbchen und
das reicht zum leben und so und auf
jeden fall haben wir dann in meinen
plattenvertrag unterschrieben oder
vorschuss kriegen aber relativ schnell
weg weil wir von einem indie-label zum
major gegangen sind dem mussten eine
entschädigung bezahlen wenn er auf tour
gegangen und da haben auch nicht so viel
verdient aber dann haben sie mir
erstmals verkauft und am ende der tour
kamen der der merchandise firma bei
denen wir mit denen wir einen vertrag
hatten die unsere t-shirts verkauft
haben und die haben jeden von uns den
anteil der verkauften t shirt in einem
blog gegeben das waren 10 d mark scheine
so ein blog wo man diese ab reißen
konnte das waren knapp 1000 100 d-mark
pro person das war unfassbar viel geld
ja das sind wir mit diesem komischen
blog kommen gelaufen
und keiner von uns war damals auch in
den bus einsteigen
wieso dann bezahlen und christian diesen
schein ab und ist nicht mitgenommen
worden weil ja
[Applaus]
und dann und dann haben wir uns mal mir
ein paar jahre wenn das immer gespielt
und es ging alles ganz gut um die
mitgekriegt nie so darum gekümmert geld
rente keine ahnung das gehört nicht zu
diesen lebensentwurf dann haben uns
aufgelöst dann wollte sich jemand von
mir geld leihen dann manchmal auf mein
konto geguckt hatte 9000 mark auf dem
konto da gar nicht so schlecht nachdem
ihr euch aufgelöst hat nachdem wir uns
aufgelöst hatten
und dann wird es ein bisschen mehr
später aber das ist eine andere
geschichte
dann aber eure rege ersten konzerte
kamen da leute oder oder ja ja wir
hatten immer viel leute aber wir werden
natürlich auch wahnsinnig günstig und ja
und würden die clubs waren halt sehr
klein villa kreuzberg zum beispiel fast
110 leute rein und sondern zweimal
hintereinander gespielt das war das ist
gut
zweimal ausverkauft 110 und 220 leute
aber kann man drauf schreiben
ausverkauft das natürlich super für das
plakat ist das gute ist ja dass verkauft
als vision berater hatten ja wir hören
oft vom von von musikern idee erzählen
dass sie eigentlich vor gar keinen
spielen also ja also getreten von
niemandem ich habe mal mit einem
schlagzeuger spielt er hatte den rekord
er hatte einen zahlenden zuschauer bei
uns war der minusrekord sechs zahlende
zuschauer 6 und haben werde ich weiß
nicht wer der schweiz gespielt und
parallel waren im fußballspiel
deutschland gegen in länderspielen
freundschaftsspiel glaube ich und da
waren einige deutsche angereist aus
deutscher und die sind nach dem spiel
zum konzept 20 oder so zum konzert
gekommen nachdem wir vor sechs leuten
schon anderthalb stunden gespielt hat
man noch mal von vorne angefangen für
die 20
[Applaus]
das war richtig richtig blutig schwere
anfänge und wenn man dann so durchs land
reist hatte dem benzin überhaupt für das
auto für den tourbus und soja das war
schon okay also so wir mussten sie haben
jetzt nicht benzin abgesaugt oder wars
ist da aber wir hatten einen bwl
studentin als bassisten die ersten jahre
das war sehr praktisch da konnten wir so
ein bisschen rum watson hatte auch als
einziger führerschein unten alten post
bus oder mit dem sind wir dann waren wir
unterschiedlich so ging das so warten
wann ging es dann richtig los mit dem
durch steigende bravo als man dann
plötzlich in der bravo stand oder aber
war was ganz anderes die bravo kamen auf
uns da hatten wir noch unsere allererste
single so ne ep
da stand unser adressen telefonnummern
und die das geld dafür hatten wir uns
gelingt von jans mutter waren urlaubs
mutter und dann wurde in bravo kommt auf
uns aufmerksam eine chefredakteur war
gerade im urlaub und hat einer der ihn
vertreten hat das auf seine kappe
genommen und da plötzlich hatten den
post seiner braven wir persönlich fahren
das mega lustig und war dann so haben
wir mit so gespielt mit dieser idee und
alle haben gedacht alter ihr seid jetzt
schwerreiche müssen wir eine ausgeben
also das ist tatsächlich ist das als wir
uns dann aufgelöst hatten da war mir
dann zum ersten mal richtig in den
charts und es hat geholfen so das haben
wir dann andere auch howard carpendale
so leute dann auch begriffen dass das
eigentlich ganz gutes mal so immer kurz
zurückzutreten um wieder zugang anmelden
da kamen da kamen dann posthum irgendwie
so plötzlich viel geld und dann haben
wir ja ich meine dass es nach späterem
verkaufszahlen tatsächlich relativ wenig
aber in den fünf jahren wo wir nicht
existiert haben haben wir nach
maueröffnung wir uns 88 auf 89 gab es
die wiedervereinigung 70.000 platten
verkauft was wir wahnsinnig viel fangen
und das hat natürlich mit der mit den
leuten aus der ddr zu tun für die wieder
totaler kult waren ja leider denken na
bravo poster coole punk band die die ddr
sozusagen das jetzt mal so salopp zu
formulieren sitzt sozusagen nebenbei
haben sie das mitgekriegt also was waren
die ärzte für sie
na ja das was wir so toll fanden war
diese dunkel cruz
darauf sind wir unheimlich abgefahren
klar
also das war schon die ärzte waren da
und du bist ein spannender groß geworden
wenn in spannender weise war direkt dran
so zu sagen na ja gut also in westberlin
was immer direkt dran
ja ich meine richtung vorgang irgendwann
war das gesagt 70.000 platten verkauft
damals wieviel habt ihr bis heute
verkaufte tonträger das ist nicht so wie
das ist nicht mein das ist wie gesagt
manchmal du weißt jetzt gar nicht ich
weiss es nicht ist ein paar millionen
schon von einzelnen platten weiß man
dann irgendwie die hat 800.000 verkaufte
eine million es gab immer leute die
besser waren aber die dann auch
irgendwann wieder ein paar jahre später
schlechter waren als ja und diesen
diesem wettkampf haben wir da gar nicht
aufgenommen
eine gewisse band in deutschland sagte
wir sind jetzt viel größer als die ärzte
gesagt ja aber ihr seid nicht größer als
rammstein also
das problem das russische liga wäre das
problem russischer milliardäre es gibt
immer einen der noch eine größere yacht
hatte die h gelost zusammen und das ist
offensichtlich auch habt ihr mal in der
ddr gespielt wähler als ärzte nein das
war das ist einer der großen
versäumnisse einer sache die ich bereue
denn wir hätten zum einen wäre es gar
nicht so schwer gewesen zum beispiel aus
berlin zu spielen sie hat ja illegale
konzerte in kirchen den toten hosen
haben es gemacht zum beispiel
wir wollten aber eine training spielen
und hatten kontakt zur zur vw
schallplatten am mega amiga und die
beuten in album von uns raus bringen
in der ddr seine best of platte und dann
eine tournee mit uns veranstaltet und
dachte mir okay es besser als dazu ein
paar geheimtipps und haben das dann
einfach auch hinzu kommen lassen und
dann wurde ein paar platten von uns
initiiert plus dass wir uns in ostberlin
mit einem dj von dt 64 radiosendern aus
berlin getroffen haben und einen
feuchtfröhlichen abend begangen haben an
dem wir vielleicht ein bisschen viel
erzählt hatten auf jedenfalls danach
unsere tour abgesagt worden und nach dem
dj auch als element war der auf uns der
rechte unserem bassisten die
freundschaft gesucht hat um was über
unsere saaten bisschen komisch so also
wir haben es verbockt immerhin gab es
dann auch eine single gab sondern erst
nach einer der die inzwischen habe ich
so viele unterschrieben dass ich ganz
sicher bin dass da irgendjemand noch
nach brest weil die haben damals zur
planwirtschaft 2000 stück gepresst und
aber ich habe schon 4000 unterschrieben
aber so wie du das jetzt hält heißt habt
ihr es ja nicht verbockt
natürlich natürlich haben wir es nicht
verboten weil wir hätten was ich hätte
einfach für mich ich hätte gerne ich
hätte das gerne in meinem colt diesen
sitzer in der ddr gespielt alle die nase
gezeigt haben aber nicht ob ich war das
nicht klar war dass das der euch
möglicherweise ausspioniert das hat das
war so ganz war diese ganze diese also
klar starten begriff aber diese ganze
sache
bei uns überhaupt nicht klar ob ich dass
wir alle diese neunziger jahren das
waren es kein bisschen klar wir hatten
ja auch ich hatte auch sogar
briefkontakt zu fans aus ostdeutschland
habe dann eine ein ganz süßer briefe ein
junge der schlagzeug spielen wollte und
in irgendeiner schlagzeugschule war und
dann wurde er nach russland verschickt
in einer jugendreise und sagte und da
hat er versucht schlagzeug sticks zu
bekommen aber es gab keine und er kann
nicht spielen da keine stöcke hat nicht
und ich hatte so die gab es ja an jeder
ecke 15 mark oder zwölf mag auch
günstiger und dann habe ich dem einfach
ein paar schlagzeug sticks geschickt und
nach maueröffnung kam der inzwischen
erwachsener mann dann irgendwie mit
diesen unterschrieben den sticks von mir
an er hatte nie bekommen
das war schon sehr gerührt und dachte
hey wir haben die sticks da
weitergeleitet ich weiß nicht was sie
damit gemacht haben
[Applaus]